[Music]
they're not the same news no no no no
made it by Chinese broccoli with oyster
sauce
what stems eat broccoli Chinese broccoli
quickly it looks way I don't even know
if it's a broccoli stana like a broccoli
stem it's closer to a broccolini than it
is to a factory is it like bok choy know
the stock is thick like broccolini you
don't want this kind of hot Wow yeah hey
did you guys some that broccoli is not a
natural vegetable her it's man-made most
of our vegetables are really did you
know that pumpkin is a fruit because of
the serious scenes behind and it grows
outside of the ground it's against
everything I believed in what's the
article a screenwriter revealed that
Julia Roberts was a studio executives
first choice to play Harriet Tubman
Jeannie ah [ __ ] Leigh now 1994 oh that's
94 they wouldn't have even acknowledged
that she was oh [ __ ] yeah
even even funnier alright so
screenwriter Gregory Allen Howard said
recently that back in 1994 when he
presented the the script that there was
this studio exact like president at the
time that he ended up saying the script
is fantastic let's get Julia Roberts to
play Harriet Tubman and then there was
someone in the room that was like um my
Harriet Tubman was black god bless that
person is this a different Harriet
Tubman well that producers probably like
never [ __ ] studied history I'll try
to give on the benefit of that Harriet
Tubman from Newport Beach no it's the
underground Road okay I'll try to help
them out but
we talk about surf shop harriet tubman
right Newport Beach Harriet Tubman I
just don't know which one
yeah so at the time she was like
America's Sweetheart
it's like movies like Steel Magnolias
pretty woman in the Pelican brief so
anyway so then when when someone
actually mentioned like she was black
right so then she replied it was so long
ago no one no one's gonna know the
difference
Oh a person being dragged through the
mud right now and our movie still can't
get made oh my god that's so rude if you
put her in a little exactly the same you
know why you know why I don't see color
you guys you guys a little racist
I don't see color I love it yeah if only
the world could be more like you
yep the locust of all yep all I see are
two beautiful women standing in front of
me I don't see color [ __ ] y'all do you
want I wish I could have been back then
during this one this photos being taken
a big Harriet Tubman you should smile
more I think that would helped her a lot
yeah just man I realized that yeah I
remember how she got [ __ ] for not
smiling I bet she was she had a sit
there just because she's a woman people
were giving her [ __ ] for not smiling and
like the promo and stuff and she was
like really and then she pulled up all
these like male actor superheroes that
never smile and they never got [ __ ] for
it yeah I smile more though how kilmer
small did Batman Forever and it was sick
yeah have you seen what Val Kilmer looks
like now huh horrifying glow it looks
bad I mean fantastic is that your friend
he looks great I why I'm a fan of Val I
feel very bad for him he will he had a
stroke oh that's why he looks like that
Tina hashtag Hansel Deena
it's so sad plastic surgery no really
you're [ __ ] me no no really
oh my god I'm so he was the original
Iceman yeah I had a crush on sit down
sorry buddy so let me help you out here
and go back he was one of my favorite
characters on your okay that particular
you have nothing to worry about Gina
he's a white man our prayers go out to
him for sure Harriette's which is the
movie we're talking about here wear it
like this grip was created back in 1994
is now being released and god damn it
took them 20 something years to make
this because the screen reader said that
like he liked he was so passionate about
this project and but every time like
just Hollywood the climate wasn't ready
for this movie yet Oh [ __ ] stupid
back then and they still are today
tomorrow like not until um run into like
black panther and I forgot already the
other movie the slave one twelve years
this like thank you longer a slave not
until those movies then like Hollywood
slowly like you know the door was open
for this movie not even roots that's
crazy that was old-school to TIF buys a
ticket for twelve years as a she's like
uh yeah one for that that slave one
[Laughter]
anything wrong with that numbers
like Joel I'm just trying to be a
sensitive response yeah this is a new
era of JK news all right it's time that
we are we got a local enough we got a
woke up patreon this is going out to the
world was just a looping video of me and
TIFF same dumb [ __ ] in this video for a
chance okay anyway so the lead actress
her name is Cynthia
areevo and she is a British actress and
because of the fact that she's a British
actress
they got backlash Oh bro that's exactly
what I American that's what I was like
how dare you cast someone who has never
faced American history woes yeah she's
toned his punk ass because the
screenwriter saw her perform and the the
color is purple but like the live one
the color Parag way the color is purple
color purple can i watch that purple
show it's about what is it what is it
it's Oprah Oprah Winfrey Steven
Spielberg Whoopi Goldberg
I know [ __ ] all I was just like I
remember being I forgot how it's just a
goodness Erebus slavery the sobbing it
was like the saddest story in my life
okay that I've ever seen okay here we go
so this is the cast Jeanette Jenelle
know I like Janelle Monae yeah is that
dude from get out the one on the left
no I thought he was the guy that
kidnapped the guy that goes like he
looks like he's the guy from Star Wars
oh not John boyega if it was a boy he'd
be at the front of the [ __ ] post is
it gonna be an action movie
yeah so the screenwriter was like trying
to like he wanted her so tight that's
powerful dad like he didn't want to give
people like a history lesson like to
preach to them like they wanted he
wanted to create Harriet and like
portray her in a way
that's it she's gonna be like John wick
and do bushu and [ __ ] I'll be dope but I
was thinking more like Django blastin
[ __ ] and say I want to review
this movie real quick I have not see
even seen this movie but because I'm so
[ __ ] woke it's a 10 10 out of 10 good
for you white guilt included it's an 11
if you were rated less than attend then
erasers Manya yeah if I rate it a four
you know what they're gonna say you know
what they're gonna say to me losing race
traders you're not you're not jumped
you're not jumping in for the minority
team oh I see we all got a band together
as well have you guys seen the trailer
actually I was really good I didn't see
the trailer yeah I didn't but I have a
friend who saw it that's good she went
to the premiere keep it up - that's good
you know for real like I got chills at
the moment she was like it was amazing
wasn't it she was like knowing the
trailer she was like I've done this all
on my own don't tell me what I can't do
and I was like yeah I did Julie Roberts
with their bed me too
she's more seasoned actually she has
that just that she's more American she
knows that American was like oh I feel
like between the two maybe the more
American one is entitled to the role
Scarlett Johansson shoulda gotten it
said Julie Roth no Scarlett Johansson is
Asian yeah she should be representing
the Asian roles well I am a stone - they
can split them that's true and till do
you know who actually could probably get
away with playing a black woman is Meryl
Streep because everyone's like [ __ ]
she's good
she's so good everyone's like [ __ ]
I'll take it Robert Downey jr. as a
black guy he did you know now everyone
crayons but that was the bit so any
because but hopefully people would
recognize the bit well yeah the bit was
you know yeah he's a pretentious actor
who's yeah yeah who thinks he's so good
that he can pull off being a black guy
yeah yeah
which is stupid as [ __ ] dude about that
dude yeah what do you mean you people
what do you mean you people
[Music]